i just want to say
to my postpartum moms that postpartum
has not been easy
it's not easy mentally
physically
spiritually
it's just
crazy kylie jenner is getting real about
giving birth to baby number two in
february the beauty mogul announced the
arrival of her and travis scott's son
wolfe in this sweet black and white
photo of their daughter stormy's hand
holding her brothers but since then
kylie reveals the journey getting back
into shape has been difficult it's not
been easy it's very hard
it's this experience for me personally
has been a little harder than with my
daughter
it's not easy mentally
physically spiritually
it's just
crazy and yeah i didn't want to just get
back to life without saying that the
reality star also reminds her followers
not everything is as it seems online i
think we can look on the internet and
you know for other moms going through
right now
um we can go on the internet and it
might look a lot easier for other people
and like put the pressure on us but it
hasn't been easy for me i didn't even
think i'd make it to this workout today
but i'm here and i'm feeling better
so
you got this
kylie then ends her message with a
positive mantra for all the mamas out
there it's okay
not to be okay once i
realized that i was putting some
pressure on myself and i just keep
reminding myself i made a whole human
beautiful healthy boy
and we have to stop putting pressure on
ourselves to
be back not even physically just
mentally
um after
after birth so yeah
just sending some love i love you guys
this honest moment from kylie comes just
days after she made her big return to
instagram following wolf's birth so i
know i've been mi for a while
stormy wants to be in this
but i launched a
new lip product
lip lacquers
get out of here yeah that's stormy
crashing her mama's video i love it and
kylie reveals her absence hasn't been in
vain she's been hard at work so i
launched a new lip product they're
called lip lacquers and i haven't been
doing my makeup so i haven't been able
to show you guys but now
i am
you know getting back to
doing my makeup
now fans are hoping to see lots of cute
moments like that in the family's
upcoming hulu reality series the
kardashians we've had so much time off
we've kind of gone into our own worlds
i'm excited for this new chapter and
i've been in this game long enough to
know that you just have to be yourself
one thing's for sure the series will
feature kylie's pregnancy journey
my pregnancy is really public this time
i feel like we're being chased and
although it seems attention surrounding
kylie's second pregnancy was pretty
intense the reward has been great a
source told e.t shortly after wolff's
arrival that the couple is over the moon
and that they both felt so ready for
this they have wanted to grow their
family and give stormy a sibling for a
while and they couldn't be happier
[Music]